- All right everybody
lets close up the hour
with something super fun I
came across on social media
this is: What I'm Liking.
(theme music)
So it's not all that common
that you see people getting married
at 77 years old, but check out
just how happy this bride is.
I love it!
Maybe it's because Dottie,
she married herself.
She's so happy right now, that's right!
She said "I do"
to a lifetime of being
with her favorite person.
And you know what? I say nicely done.
Yeah!
(audience cheer)
We have her on the line right now
watching on WCPO9.
Well Dottie you might be the only person
that we know for sure
you're not getting divorced.
(Dottie laughs)
So describe your wedding!
- I got married in my retirement home,
and I had a lot of friends and family.
And my daughter fixed
everybody a nice plate.
And I had a cake and some flowers.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- And I was so excited!
(audience cheers)
I was so excited.
- So Dottie, have you
ever been married before
to not yourself?
Have you ever been
married to anybody else?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh you have been?
- I got married in a courthouse
with a black dress on.
In 40 years I decided, I loved myself.
And I wanted to do something
special for myself.
So, I married myself.
(audience applause)
- [Kelly] Oh I love you
so much thank you Dottie!
I'm loving your post right now.
And that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of G2 the -
- Look at this look at this. Oh my God.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my God wow!
- [Kelly] What?!
You are so funny!
I was like, "What are you doing?"
How are you?
- I'm good.
- Are you-
- Where should I stand?
Hello! How are you?
(audience cheers)
- Are you doing Jimmy tonight?
- Yeah.
- Yeah I'm doing Jimmy.
- Oh my God I was like
we always run into people in the hallway
- I'm actually in New York city,
we just announced a world
tour for 30 Seconds to Mars
so I'm celebrating.
- We just were at iHeart together.
We both did that show together so that-
You sounded incredible man!
I can not wait to go see your show.
- Thank you thank you.
I appreciate it. It's been six years.
So we just put a new album
out, and now we have a new tour
and it's incredible, yeah.
- Oh my God I love it.
I'm so stoked for yall.
Yall sound incredible.
It was a great show.
I love that you stopped by.
- I appreciate it yeah.
Its been a crazy day.
I climbed the empire state
building this morning.
So I'm a little- I'm a little tired.
- What?!
- No they think I'm
joking, I actually did.
- [Kelly] Wait what?
You really climbed the
empire state building?
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] I didn't even
know you- I didn't-
Why- What- Did- Was it a- Was it a bet?
- It's just to celebrate the
launch of the tour, you know?
I've always loved the
empire state building.
Every since I was a kid
I was fascinated by it.
Probably not the only one,
but it always was a
symbol to me of New York,
and of following your dreams.
So I thought
what a great way to launch
the tour with the band.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. That's really cool.
You're a brave- I just you know-
- [Jared] Tired man.
- I just say "I'm going on
tour" that the way I do it.
I love it! You just swung by.
- Yeah!
- [Kelly] Do you wanna say
goodbye to America with me?
- [Jared] Yeah. I would love to.
- We're gonna maybe give some money away.
You wanna do that with me?
- Wow my pleasure.
- Our season long partner
Pilot Pen maker of G2,
this is incredible.
I love 30 rock you have no
idea what's going to happen.
The going to of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly and
support all the people
just like you Dottie.
She just married herself.
Congratulations Dottie. Yes.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars
as a wedding gift Dottie.
So you're getting a thousand dollars!
- I'm so excited.
- [Kelly] Thank you to
all our guests this hour
Jule, Sheila E, Ashley
Flowers, Carly Michael,
and Kate Taylor.
Yall have a great day and if it's not,
maybe Jared Leto will
pop up and make your day.
(audience cheers)
(band plays)